hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Steinitz
Memorial yesterday we've seen a game
where Magnus had the white pieces
against wiggler and he went for that
well c3a followed by c4 idea which India
and then the robot both players had
their chances but now we are checking
out to the game where sweet learn has
the white pieces and it's also a very
interesting game so I hope you hope you
enjoyed the podcast yesterday in my game
against mvl if you still haven't seen it
I will put links to both the podcast and
my game against anvil in the description
below so do check it out as it was very
enjoyable at least for me so getting
back to this one and also I mentioned in
the previous video that there's Tiny's
memorial is a part of the Carson Chester
which is not now I mixed it up with the
online chess masters tournament which is
not this one so this is not a part of
the Carlsen Chester just straighten that
out so getting back to the game sweedler
with the white pieces opens with E 4 we
have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 the real opus is on the
board and now Knight to f6 by Magnus
goes for the Berlin defense we have D 3
and D 6 and they will be following the
game across and played against Fallujah
also with the black pieces in the Tata
Steel masters in January so castles and
Bishop to e7 or everything the same as
in the game against future we have c3
castles and rook to e1 so basically all
standard Berlin stuff we have a 6 Bishop
to a4 and rook to e8 Knight B to d2 and
here we reach the position where cross
and played Bishop to f8 against Fallujah
in the data stonemasters but here he
goes for b5 first so pushing the bishop
back Bishop to c2 and only now Bishop to
f8 we have
d4 striking in the center now that the
e4 pawn has sufficient defense and
Bishop the b7 by Magnus with a 4 are
already attacking here I did he expanded
pawn on b5 and now Knight the b8 by
Magnus preparing c5 rather making room
for the C pawn so you can move it and
here at Bishop to d3 by spoiler stopping
c5 because c5 would be just met with a
capture son b5 and you lose the pawn
here
so carlson cannot play c-5a rather you
can there actually is one give me the
database where c5 was played here but
Cox and chooses c6 and it is as of move
13 that we have a completely new game
so with b3 swiller prepares now to finca
to his dark squared bishop and the
Knight B to d7 now the night is coming
to b6 we have Queen to c2 developing the
Queen and now Queen to c7 across and
does the same Bishop to b2 and now
Knight to h5 as we cross and now once
they're shifted the night over to f4 and
this wheeler wants to kick it away he
will have to weaken the King side with
the g3 so first settler prepares it
bishop to f1 gains control of of the
white squares here we have Knight to f4
and now g3 kicking the night Wayne also
the Bishop covers the h3 squares we have
to go back Knights the e6 and now b4 by
Sevilla
we have night the b6 here across and is
inviting Spiller to push a5 but if you
push a 5 then with the Queen side being
locked down there black is the one who
will be choosing when when there will be
a breakthrough in the position so here
instead Svidler trades with a captured C
captures and now it is kind of tough
with this backwards c3 pawn but fiddler
immediately finds a way how to get rid
of it he plays d5 attacks the night here
and now if you move back with an idea
then you go c4 and you no longer have to
worry about your backwards c3 pawn and
also you free or dark square bishop so
instead Magnus went Knights the d4 as
you cannot capture because your Queen
would be hanging on c2 so Knight
captures on d4 we have see a ECAP force
on d4 and now only see 4 so here sailor
again gets rid of his it backwards c3
pawn and opens up an attack against a
crossings d4 pawn so rook a to c8
putting more pressure on the c4 pawn and
here's wheeler grabs the d4 pawn so
Bishop captures Knight captures and now
we have captures on c4 be characters on
c4 and now rook a to C one sailor wants
to eliminate Carlsen's past the C pawn
but cousin finds a very nice way how to
complicate matters he pushes f5 once the
weekend the d5 pawn so now obviously if
you capture then you can
capture capture here it's not a problem
so Spiller finds the Bishop to h3
preventing this idea as the bishop at
the broken c8 would hang and now you
don't really have a you don't really
have a good way of continuing this so
Magnus finds the basically the only way
to play with black he sacrifices the
exchange on c8 so f captures on e4 we
have Bishop captures on c8 rook captures
on c8 and now Queen captures on e4 and
Queen to f7 so sacrificing the exchange
but but he still has the bishop pair he
has the past C pawn and he will win the
d4 pawn which will give him a lot of
pressure along this diagonal so Queen g4
base fielder puts pressure on the g7
pawn and the Queen captures on d5 now
threatening Queen Queen to g2 or Queen
to h1 checkmate
so Quinta ECX check the only move that
that gives white some advantage so
trading the Queen's we have Queen
captures rook captures and the now comes
King to f7 attacking the rook in the rug
back to e3 are keeping an eye on the on
the c3 square and now Magnus will try he
he is up upon and he still has the
bishop pair so what he wants is to
somehow create a set up these pawns can
start marching forward so he starts with
Bishop to d5 we have Bishop to c3 by
swiller
so still keeping an eye on that g7 pawn
the bishop is very nicely placed on this
diagonal and also you just want to block
the c4 pawn and also keep an eye on the
deep one by controlling the d4 square so
Bishop the c6 of course the Magnus will
somehow try to get this pawn rolling
down the board we've looked at a 1 and
going after the pawn here and not rook
the a8 here we will look back to e 1 and
now comes d5 so still you don't really
have a good way of playing d4 rook to f3
check King g8 and now look the e6
putting the pressure on the bishop we
have rook the ca defending now and rook
to f4 now and now with the Bishop
blockading the C pawn and the bishop and
rook controlling the d4 square it will
be very hard for Magnus to execute d4
here so brush up the b5 now and here we
have h4
starting to pull th point up the board I
really put pressure on black skin side
we've worked a d8 now somehow maybe
maybe you can somehow get let's say g6
or maybe Bishop to g7 in either get rid
of the dark square bishop or maybe just
start pushing the pawn but it's still
it's still a long way to go from here so
look the b6 now you already have ideas
of putting more pressure on the g7 pawn
the bishop still controls this diagonal
you can go rogue b7 to further attack it
you can go rogue g4 to add another
attacker so a lot of ideas here for
white Magnus goes to Bishop to d6
attacks the rook and rook to g4 now now
there of course is the threat of just
Rock a force on g7 so rook the d7
defends it and now h5 by Sevilla Bishop
characters and g7 is also just the
winning but not also Bishop g7 is
winning here but he goes for h5 first
and now h6 by Magnus and here rook to g6
are still not going for this Bishop
characters and g7 idea as after the rook
moves you will be able to recapture here
but rather now creating a double attack
on the bishop here but it's three plus
two of course both players being very
low on time you don't have a lot of time
to calculate lines so Bishop the f8 the
bishop again defends the g7 pawn and now
Bishop the d4 you don't want to meet d4
here so Bishop d4 and here a cross and
misses the the idea of rook to c7 would
rook to c7 you are threatening to just
push and promote your pawn and the
problem is after Bishop to c3 you still
push d4 and you will have a much better
position bishop characters you're gonna
go c3 and after you get this position
then it's just much better with the
passport already being uncie - however
magnus went bishop capture son before he
decided to grab this and create two
connected passed pawns but now it no
longer works
now swiller played bishop sorry rook to
b8 with check we have king to h7 and now
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning move for a swindler as
it is an unstoppable mate in five so
feel free to try and find it while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
have to prevent the king from reaching
the g5 square and from those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's f4 that's the stuff and now there
really isn't much you can do here it
doesn't really matter what what you play
the continuation is pretty much the same
if you if you move the rook away from
the defense of the pond and obviously
just wrote characters and g7 will be
checkmate
so here Magnus played c3 he started
pushing his past pawn but now comes the
move you had to see in order to find f4
it's rook captures on h6 with check and
it was in this position unmoved 48 that
magnus carlsen resigned the game as if
there is nothing more to be done here
and yes it is quite similar to cross
since Queen captures and h6 against
Sarah Kerrigan in their World Chess
Championship match which basically
acclaimed him the title point is that it
doesn't matter what you capture we do
capture with the pawn rook to h8 is mate
as the bishop defends it ended upon
prevents the King from reaching g6 and
of course if you capture with the King
and now you see the importance of the f4
move rook to h8 is checkmate because the
King cannot reach the g5 Square so
really really really awesome stuff by
swiller finding both f4 and this rook
captors and h6 idea so nicely done and
yeah Magnus Magnusson take advantage of
his his chance with the white pieces of
going for that c3 idea and now will
retaliate sin in full capacity with a
beautiful game like this so after rook
captures and h6 Magnus resigned and
we're gonna cover a few more games and
then we're gonna check out the standings
of the time it's Memorial so that that's
it for for the moment once again do
check out the podcast if you haven't and
also my game against MDL both links will
be in the description below I would like
to thank Nicolas Bruno Peter Keller
Jacques approch
Vishnu mocha party and Mark Pryor for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga and checking up on whatever
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday